new turnover at the White House could
signal a major shift in American foreign
policy president Trump tapped former UN
Ambassador John Bolton to become his
third national security adviser
yesterday he replaces HR McMaster who
took over after Michael Flynn was fired
Bolton is known for advocating hardline
positions on Iran and North Korea
his appointment is raising concern about
an increased possibility of military
conflict in different global crises chip
Reid is at the White House chip good
morning well good morning John Bolton
has served three Republican presidents
most recently George W Bush he has a
divisive foreign policy figure and I say
what you mentioned he has advocated the
use of force against both Iran and North
Korea and his selection signals a
hawkish turn for president Trump they'll
always be change the reshaping of the
president's White House team continued
Thursday when mr. Trump replaced a
national security adviser HR McMaster
with whom he never clicked personally
with John Bolton a foreign policy hawk
whose views more closely mirror his own
the Bolton for McMaster swap had been
rumored for weeks yet even after Bolton
was spotted at the White House yesterday
advisors denied the change was afflict
it's still sinking in the president's
announcement left even Bolton surprised
he appeared on Fox News less than an
hour after the tweet didn't really
expect an announcement this this
afternoon Bolton has promoted the use of
force in both Iran and North Korea
writing last month that it was perfectly
legitimate to strike North Korea first
and in 2015 recommending the u.s. bomb
Iran the Iran deal is coming up in May
the president will decide whether to
remain in the Iran nuclear deal Bolton a
fierce opponent of the Accord is
expected to argue for withdrawal
decertify and exit the deal and there is
the pending summit with North Korean
leader Kim jong-un I think they want to
make peace I think it's time Bolton's
new role could scramble the White
House's preparations for the proposed
meeting talking to the North Koreans is
a waste of time
there was also turnover on the
president's legal team Thursday as the
lead lawyer dealing with Special Counsel
Robert Muller's Russia investigation
John Dowd
signed Dowd was squeezed out when the
president hired former US Attorney Joe
digenova
earlier this really charged sources say
Dowd was also very much opposed to the
president doing an interview with Muller
something mr. Trump said yesterday that
he would like to do during the last Bush
administration members of both parties
in the Senate tried to block his
appointment as UN ambassador but his new
job as national security adviser doesn't
require Senate confirmation so you've
got Bolton coming in you've also got
Mike Pompeo the hawkish CIA director
who's going to be Secretary of State
some animals say the only person left at
the top of the president's foreign
policy team who's a voice of moderation
is Secretary of Defense Jim mattis Gayle
all right thank you chip